alright this is a pepper panic saga
level 2 59 walkthrough tutorial this is
a level that's very difficult and a lot
of people are having problems with it in
our group and pretty much everywhere so
I'm going to go ahead and play through
it and try to explain things as I go and
talk about setting up these high pepper
matches that you need to make one thing
you can keep in mind is when you're
playing the the level it's long it's it
can be very frustrating so you get a
board like this where you don't have any
real gaps like I don't have pairs of two
Reds anywhere that I can kind of get
together you can always just go ahead
and quit and try to get a different
board like I said you don't want to get
super frustrated just on the very first
match so it's never a bad idea to do
that if that's the case this looks a
little bit better because we have some
may have parts of what we need
but we don't have a whole lot as far as
making matches underneath it let's see
how this looks we want to do is get this
red pepper right here
alright now we also have the gap going
up so if we can get this one right here
that would be just as good but there we
have it you know we know we want to move
that one down so we just want to work
out on the right side and and get things
to fall into place for so there's our
first match now quick look around and
it's easy to see that there's no yellow
gaps whatsoever there's barely any
yellow peppers and they're all far apart
from each other so what I'm going to do
here is is try to rearrange the board as
fast as possible and like you know the
purple we know from from the tips and
everything that the purple is the last
five ever match so there's no no reason
to try to save that match or whatever
just just go ahead and use that to clear
the board quick
now we'll look things over again and see
what a fee l bar set up a little better
for us all right so now we have some
some pairs at least you know when
they're we got one there
this one is is set off to the side so we
can't really mess with that alright so
this is a this is this is the the gap
we're looking for right here however if
we make the red match first and let this
drop they're going to combine together
so we have to do first is just move that
one over then move that one down not
only can make a match and lose um not
much a little bit of a setup here but no
way to get it together right away now
one thing to keep in mind is when you're
whenever you make those five pepper
matches they grow all that same color so
you can usually start a panic with that
color pretty quickly if you go to do
that though just um after each match
just look around the board to make sure
you don't miss anything
so and it also gets a little bit harder
to see you whenever there's a lot of
grown pepper sitting around so just take
a little extra time the Blues are all
there they've got this big diagonal line
they're all spread out pretty bad so I'm
just going to go ahead and continue to
try to get rid of the try to get a panic
started can't match any yellows together
directly and clear this row and see if
we get a yellow to line up we did check
the Blues we have a couple
but this is all a mess down here so we
can't really match through it so we'll
switch things up and see what happens
there's a lot of colors here you don't
you know it's not like level 95 where
you can do that and catch a lot of your
matches in the in the Cascade but it can
happen so you know you have to it's
better than moving things around for no
reason for sure all right so you can see
we have like most of the gap here but we
can't we can't get anything together we
have half of it here if we could get to
blue peppers to drop that way that
wouldn't be bad but other than that it's
pretty much there's pretty much nothing
going on go ahead and move those
together and now we have the the fifth
one we need here this will get it closer
there we go
now I kind of it's kind of a bummer when
you think that we had to match we had
that green when together but we want to
be able to get to the blue ones if we
didn't use it so like I said there's
really not that much reason to try to
save those matches unless you know you
know for sure you can you can make your
match that you need without you know
work around it but I wouldn't mate I
wouldn't waste moves because it's going
to the board is going to switch up no
matter what you do to so as things fall
down so we have parts of our gaps here
you know we could try to move some some
green peppers down this row but we also
have a lot of larger pepper sitting
around so
I'm going to match blues to get them
ready to explode and just see if
anything materializes here I can't
really go out of my way that much for it
so if we want to match if you want to
grab balloon what would be the best way
I mean I can I can explode the green
right now I the one thing that I'm kind
of afraid of is that if I if I start to
panic with green no green that are going
to be as many green peppers that follow
the board you can see that most of the
red ones aren't grown and the yellow
ones aren't grown so those are going to
kind of be the ones that are left behind
after so i guess in a way it doesn't
matter all of those green peppers are
going to get clear anyways
it's kind of holding my breath watching
that one there we go all right so now we
just need a purple we have the gap right
here and we have part of it down here
the only problem is is if we make this
match that over here we're going to get
some matches and some other things are
going to happen and we're going to lose
the one at the top so we also have it
right here which we can set up directly
that's probably going to be the easiest
one to work with I'm going to go ahead
and see if we can't get a red one that
are purple one to drop right in first or
am I so we don't have we don't we don't
have like a great match to drop on in
here yeah what I'm going to do is I'm
going to match the purple that's going
to drop some things down and it's also
going to keep this red one in place so I
can i can try one more time and we won't
lose our gap here so all right so that
now we can just forget about that up
there
let's get that green one out of the way
now we could drop the purple but it's
going to match with this one so that
doesn't work
hmm
where we can make it here
which might be the best thing to do but
how do we get that out there
trying to get a blue one over here so
that I can clear the space and get the
purple in the drop-down form and that's
it so you can see that if you plan it
out you can actually work your way
through it takes a while I mean this is
a 12-minute video and I would i wish i
coulda made it a little bit shorter but
it's kind of one of those things if you
have any questions about setting those
matches up or anything leave a comment
and let us know hope this helps you out
I know it's a frustrating level but take
a break if you need to and just focus on
setting up those things and those gaps
and you'll eventually get it alright
thanks